researchers want to know what may be
causing a rare eye cancer in two states
first a group of 18 patients was
identified in Huntersville North
Carolina well now there's a second group
in auburn alabama home of auburn
university ocular melanoma is usually
found in just six of every 1 million
people and a warner spoke with victims
who share other connections and a good
morning good morning Nora and this eye
cancer is so rare
doctors say having a group of for
younger women is unusual but what is
even more striking is that all four of
them attended Auburn University in the
same timeframe and three of them were
and are friends friends often have
something in common but in this group
it's something no one would envy they
all developed a rare eye cancer called
ocular melanoma Juli Green was first at
age 27 she saw odd flashes of light he
said there is a mass there there's
something they don't know what it is it
looks like it could be you know a tumor
I mean it's like you had just had the
breath knocked out of you you know in
2001 it was her college friend Allison
Allred 31 at the time I was just seeing
some mild flashes of light first say 7
to 10 days a doctor told her she had a
detached retina but then he said well
it's detached because there's a
10-millimeter melanoma sitting on it a
large tumor both women had to have an
eye removed then their friend Ashley
McCreary found black spots in her iris
it was the same rare cancer what's crazy
is literally standing there I was like
well I know two people we've had this
cancer you know Giuliana hasson and did
you understand then how strange that was
now now I didn't strange enough that she
mentioned it to dr. Marlena Orloff the
oncologist treating her at Jefferson
University Hospital in Philadelphia
most people don't know anyone with this
disease just six in every 1 million
people are diagnosed with ocular
melanoma each year but groups of people
in two cities have now developed the
cancer Huntersville North Carolina and
now Auburn and we said okay these girls
were in this
location they were all definitively
diagnosed with this very rare cancer
what's going on dr. Orloff and her
colleagues are now studying these
patients many of whom traveled to
Philadelphia for treatment another
Auburn grad Laurie Lee kept her eye but
the cancer metastasized to her liver she
now travels from Alabama to Philadelphia
every six weeks to be treated in a
clinical trial this is a rare cancer so
it's not like you can just go anywhere
and have anybody know anything really
about it there is no known cure Allyson
Allred's cancer has recurred nine times
in six places in her body
two days ago found out that it's come
back to my brain so I'm actually gonna
have radiation on my brain tomorrow how
do you sit there with a smile given
everything that you've been through it's
totally the Lord it's totally the Lord
has carried us through every step of it
the other thing that's you know kind of
touchy is that people think of what
happened to the three of you as a
disfiguring injury that was very hard
for me you know growing up the one thing
that I liked about myself but their own
struggles motivated them to help find
other cancer victims Ashleigh McCreary
started a Facebook page so far she says
36 people have responded saying they too
attended Auburn University and have been
diagnosed with ocular melanoma we
believe and when we're looking at what's
going on in Huntersville North Carolina
and what's going on here there is
something that potentially links us
together until we get more research into
this then we're not going to we're not
going to get anywhere we've got to have
it so that we can start blinking all of
them together to try to find a cause and
then one day hopefully hopefully a cure
now Albert University officials say they
are hopeful that research and awareness
will advance the prevention and
treatment of this cancer the Alabama
Department of Health believes that it
would be premature to determine that a
cancer cluster exists that's a very
specific term a cluster and people want
to say there's a cluster doesn't mean
there's an
cluster link to one thing yeah that's an
amazing coincidence amazing coincidences
and right now everybody wants to know
what's causing it right that's that
physicians could tell us from being in
Philadelphia was that they think that
there may be an environmental cause but
so far we're not learning what that
might mean is there a larger state or
federal agency that's looking into it
about this connection well so far we
know that the state it sort of been
state by state North Carolina looked
into it didn't find anything definitive
in Huntersville out of their study
so now Alabama and Auburn University has
set up a task force yeah by a physician
there because they are trying to help
yeah because again we don't there's
nothing you know that it links to Auburn
it's just that they went to army
environmental is worrying if you're in
that environment yeah right that is high
stakes an important detective work thank
you Anna